cesari bonjour merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france l'écart se
resserre entre les deux candidats
cependant joe biden dispose d'un
avantage face à l'actuel locataire de la
maison blanche
est ce que pour vous les jeux sont faits
est-ce que voilà le prochain le futur
président des états unis et de weiden
selon vous je pense que maintenant en
ballottage très favorable parce que il
est quand même très précis le suspect
sur le disent ils si on rajoute le matin
qui a pas encore fini de compter il y
est quasiment en plus si le je vois
quand en géorgie là une petite avance à
juger ce sera assez long parce que tous
les côtés des militaires qui vont
arriver il faut encore tous les
militaires vont voter pour trump puisque
trump les méprise ouvertement
donc moi je pense quand même que la
balade est en opposition dénonce à bord
depuis le début de ces élections
présidentielles américaines on
s'attendait à une vague bleue
c'est à dire que les démocrates rafle
beaucoup plus facilement certains états
des états clés aussi qui pourrait
basculer dans leur camp que nous
apprennent finalement ces élections que
donald trump a un électorat solide tout
de même il regarde à long terme
les courbes de tension nouveau tout peut
bouger et eu un emballement des sondages
les derniers jours alors des démocrates
peut-être parce qu'il ya des gens qui
aiment anti route et les shows du people
pour trois nuls qui distille qui volent
bas et d'un autre on ne sait pas trop
effectué il ya un fond il ya un feutre
up
si on regarde un peu lâche au crash
électorale ces prêts nets trop mais
l'élu et le choix des campagnes
et des petites villes il ya vraiment une
différence je dirai comment dire ville
campagne qui est impressionnante même
temps certains états où on voit par
exemple le michigan la grande les
grandes villes les trois c'est ccba et
d'année puis les régions plus rurales
des régions plus rurales au nord ouest
c'est plutôt très justement est-ce que
l'électorat républicain a changé autres
fonds de l'impression que c'était plus
voilà la bourgeoisie américaine qui
votaient pour les républicains
on a l'impression qu'aujourd'hui ce vote
est beaucoup plus populiste beaucoup
plus rural alors les république a
effectivement réussi depuis une
cinquantaine d'années maintenant il y
aura peu près tous les conservatismes à
la fois le conservatisme économique
parce que les les milieux d'affaires
suivants qui sont qui travaillent sur le
marché intérieur ou qu'ils travaillent
pour les ou pour l'exportation sont
divisés entre démocrates et républicains
le conservatisme social et culturel
puisque manifestement là c'est comment
dire il ya un côté réactions culturel je
suis républicain qui est évident et
c'est effectivement cet aspect réaction
culturel qui leur permet de s'en tenir à
la fois le lait comment dire les gens
qui sont pauvres qui aurait pas intérêt
économiquement a voté pour le
républicain mais qui pour attache moi
donc à des valeurs anciennes
vous ne pourrez plus du tout raciste
subliminal il est de moins en moins
subliminale jamais l'amérique n'avait
été autant dit
et
le vois bien deux camps de visage
complètement différent d'ailleurs on a
pu voir hier soir par exemple les
sympathisant du camp républicain dans
certains bureaux de vote ils l'exigent
voilà que les votes soient comptabilisés
dans d'autres où ils sont où ils ont un
avantage d'arrêter les votes est ce
qu'on doit craindre
voilà des violences des imite même
parfois dans certaines il s'en fout
c'est possible il faut le scénario qu'on
a actuellement était prévu depuis des
mois une petite victoire de thé byden et
puis de des multiples recours de la part
de l'administration trump en plus pour
une vraie vie dans le journal que tron
de remonter aux besoins à la cour
suprême
on verra s'il accepte de se saisir du
cab et si c'est le cas madame barrette
et là évidemment pour faire peser la
balance
est ce que je nous reverse acceptera
c'est une autre affaire parce qu'il veut
porter la sitution les les émeutes on va
voir c'est une possibilité puisque vous
vous souvenez que trump avait dit ou
pourquoi il va se tenir prêt au cas où
nous nous verrons je leur ai vu je te
dire un petit poids parce qu'on en parle
un petit peu moins c'est le sénat où
manifestement que ça va être extrêmement
serré et il ya quand même une certaine
défaite possible pour la gauche du parti
démocrate dans ce cas là puisque baydan
va tirer argument de la bulle fait de
coûts sénat les l'cie et ce sera
certainement à 50 50 ou à peu près donc
il faudra quand même composer avec les
républicains et bagdad
on commence déjà à en tirer argument de
l'un des dirigeants démocrates pour
dilater trop à gauche
donc même s'il est élu il faudra pas
s'attendre à des cheveux comme le seach
parce que le sénat sera du côté
républicain
peut-être pas ils ont sait pas trop pour
l'instant s'il serait sans doute pas 50
50 ce qui implique de trouver des
majorités un peu un peu
buffon casser le party en tout cas pour
l'instant donald trump crient à la
fraude massive
on se souvient qu'en 2000 à l'époque il
y avait eu un bras de fer entre al gore
et george bush les résultats avaient
d'ailleurs retardé jusqu'au 13 décembre
on sait que le 14 décembre les grands
électeurs doivent voilà se prononcer sur
le futur président des états unis est ce
qu'on se dirige vers le même cas de
figure on sait que donald trump vous
l'avez dire veut saisir la justice
alors c'est possible parce que si les
choses si effectivement le nevada
aujourd'hui nous donne de son art et
mangeait mal de 170 ch qu'est-ce qu'on
sera sera mais les regroupent vont être
comptabilisés le devons être eu
certainement passer devant les cours des
divers états puisque c'est le kit qui
décide
il est possible effectivement qu'il ait
la certitude qu'on est en gros de 170
revendiqué je pense par baden on va y
arriver mais qu'ensuite le temps que ce
soit contesté jusqu'au 14 décembre c'est
tout à fait possible en effet
merci beaucoup laurent césar et d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes professeur d'histoire
contemporaine à l'université d'harvard